that day when the bus driver asked me to
get up I had this feeling come over me
it felt like how are your Tubman was
holding me down hands while holding me
down on one shoulder and so John 'true
hands were holding me down on I love the
show and I was glued to the seat and I
could hear the white passion is saying
she got a move she got a room that's the
law it's Anatomy and I felt like this is
my time to take a stand for justice my
name is Claudette Colvin and in 1955 I
refused to give up my seat to a white
passenger on the bus in Montgomery
Alabama nine months before Rosa Parks I
was 15 years old and the rule and the
segregation that a white person had to
sit in front of you and you sit behind
them and so the bus driver asked me to
get up I was shouting it's not
constitutional right so another aloof
and that's when the bus the policeman
dragged me off the bus most people ask
me when you're afraid when I was a
teenager I was afraid but I was more
angry and said it's white passengers and
then they took me and booked me I still
vividly can hear that the sound of the
Kegel and I was terrified and I started
reciting the Lord's Prayer I will be
doing in earth as it is in heaven and I
was just praying for help you know to
pray that they were going to it my
parents know that I was in jail my
mother would say yeah Florida I think he
was anointed by God to do this I don't
think so my idea
I just felt that this was not right I
just wanted people to come together and
unify and fight the segregation
[Music]
my favorite part about doing murals is
the opportunity to reach someone that
usually wouldn't be around me
this mural is called breathe deep and I
believe that you learned your best
lessons when you're not expecting to
learn my name is Fabian Williams I'm an
artist working in the great city of
Atlanta I've done over a dozen murals in
the city I came from advertising and the
type of work that I used to do was
primarily to sell products that you
don't need at a certain point I just
kind of felt like I was using my powers
for the wrong reasons
my work is a mix of race politics and
humor so I painted Martin Luther King
floating up in space pointing down at
you because you have to do to work you
have to realize the dream I've come to
believe that space is wisdom and when I
imagined where someone like Martin
Luther King came from it went back to it
would be space
I chose Hosea because his story is kind
of amazing he was a Purple Heart
recipient he was like the general of the
four People's Campaign under Martin
Luther King he joined the civil rights
movement he did a lot of community
building he did a lot of really great
things the conversation that I'm having
with my work is that we need new leaders
I want someone to walk by one of those
murals and build a connection there's
another Hosea Williams here there's
another Martin Luther King jr. here
they're walking around here if they just
don't know it yet these kids should be
able to get up and walk outside the
house and be inspired
[Music]
dance is something that comes in every
last one of us from birth what we do is
take that and give them an opportunity
to personalize it and then it empowers
us to dance at this level
my name is Melvin Mitchell Aiko and I'm
the founder of Northwest tap connection
our mission is to close the gap for
underserved communities with an emphasis
on children of color and really just
open that door for young people who
would not be able to have accessibility
to the arts because of cost to have
those opportunities stood over enriching
when I started off with staff I was
working for the set of Police Department
and my goal was their children that I
got to see on a weekly basis I would
never see across my desk tap dancing is
the foundation of our organization I
strive to make sure that children
understand that it is a dance form that
comes out of black culture it comes out
of protest and we have to appreciate it
embrace it and protect it as we pass it
down
Northwest tap is a race and social
justice oriented studio and being an
african-american male I don't think had
I danced at another studio that I would
have been surrounded by so many fellow
african-americans and I feel like that
has given me the confidence to feel
comfortable in my skin and normal
everyday life I don't really like
talking very much but when it comes to
dancing I am able to just communicate in
a way that touches people rather than
what they're just hearing my feelings as
I watched young people dance there is
this sense of pride for the work that
they do but then at the same time
there's this sense of fear and trouble
for me how much longer will we continue
with this struggle dance is such an
empowering tool we are communities of
many colors many genders identifications
but we are one drew these children that
dance we're creating a new tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shootings the
city so far this year it's time for
someone to step up and stop from the
driver
[Music]
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a present and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with a kid
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart there have been no
shootings on that block no shootings no
murders there hasn't even been as much
as a fistfight there's a sense of hope
that they didn't have before it all
because were mothers and you don't want
to underestimate the power of the mother
[Music]
racism and xenophobia are unfortunately
everywhere however one woman is turning
this into this meet Germany's hate
destroyer
[Music]
in Germany former teacher M elements s
ROM has made her life mission to remove
any neo-nazi stickers and graffiti
around her country it's no easy feat
though nine and how does one arm oneself
for a war against street 8 medium parent
a Chava or then a collection fan order
evening father Mel has been covering
removing and obscuring these messages
since the 80s she keeps a record of
everything she's wiped out all over her
country sadly Janowitz might resume you
have a receiver you busy Monday please
Allison food fanatic about comma every
day except for Sunday's her Mela packs
her bags and heads off to the streets
sometimes she knows a big one like this
heart it used to be a swastika other
times it's small but even the crudest
message doesn't slip by my new short
site violated Roku Prague
the sphere Thunder Nazi [ __ ] hi - who
finished a farmer that photometer poo on
achievement in Etihad SEPA do a gamma
started as vomit there shot - leyland it
would take first to admit difficulties
if it'll hold and as long as as hate in
this world no mela will be there can in
hand and if noise can tell descent
Manish and Mahajan comment on a device
hurt after teachers and let the
scientists have inter gives now English
of freedom
[Music]
you
[Music]